Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
We had the occasional guests related fiasco
last minute today, and that seems
to happen to us about every three to four
months.
So we are going to go to the phones and take
a few phone calls right after the first day
of Donald Trump's Senate impeachment trial.
The number of course is (617) 830-4750.
Want to see what is on people's minds.
Let's start today with our color from the
three four, six area code color from three
four, six.
What's your name and where are you calling
from?
Hi.
Gave the good morning.
My name's Jacob.
I'm calling from Denver, I'm a third year
law student and about to graduate.
You got a very simple question for you.
What do you make of the Trump campaign or
not the Trump campaign, the Trump white house
recruiting Alan Dershowitz for his defense?
Yeah, we, we talked about this a little bit.
I mean, listen, there's, Trump chooses lawyers
and chooses staff very much by media presence.
And Alan Dershowitz has become a big media
defender of Donald Trump's.
I don't know why Dershowitz is doing it.
I don't think it's for the money.
Well, w their show, which is, you know, eight
years old and, and more than wealthy enough
that he doesn't need to make another dollar
for the rest of his life.
It may be that he likes the idea of being
publicly associated with and in cahoots with
and hanging out with a sitting president.
I don't really know what's up with Alan Dershowitz,
but the reason Trump chose him is because
Dershowitz very publicly, publicly, him and
Trump just loves having people around him
that are in media saying, uh, things that
Trump wants to hear it quite plainly.
I think it's absolutely incredible that Dershowitz
is still working.
The media, I mean made a humongous name for
himself with the OJ trial.
And it's a, it's just interesting from a law
student perspective to view what's going on.
Well, it's also interesting because during
the Clinton impeachment, Dershowitz and Kenneth
star were on opposite sides and Dershowitz
actually said Kenneth star is dangerous in
what he was doing to bill Clinton.
Now Trump has hired both Dershowitz and kind
of start another working together.
Right.
How do you think this impeachment Senate trial
is going to be different than the Clinton's
Royale?
Well, it's, it's 20 years later, right?
So the media environment is so drastically
different that they're, you know, Fox news
exists, there is an entire cottage industry
of people writing books and having media presences
either on their own programs or going on other
people's programs solely based on defending
Donald Trump no matter what he does.
That's going to make this so different from
what happened with bill Clinton and the, the
media is a huge part of what makes that different
social media as well.
With the 24 hour news cycle.
I mean, how is that going to affect this?
Senator Rob mean this, this story has, um,
I think defeated that kind of 24 hour news
cycle.
I mean, it's on all the time.
Everyone's talking about it.
Um, what's going to change?
How is this rapid news cycle going to be different?
Well, again, because you have a constant streaming
of everything online, the ability to at any
time of day go and find opinion about how
Trump is either obviously guilty or obviously
innocent.
It's just going to further reinforce the echo
chambers where when you had, you know, 30
minute nightly news, uh, summing up what took
place that day, uh, it did not allow for these,
uh, an unbreakable echo chambers that we now
see.
Jacob, I'm going to let you go.
Appreciate the phone call.
I've got a bunch of people waiting to get
on.
Let's go next to our caller from the seven
one six area code.
Who's calling today from seven one six.
I gave it.
This is Sean from Buffalo.
Hey Sean.
What's up?
I wanted to know what your stance on infant
male circumcision is.
Oh, I'm for a parent's basically deciding,
uh, what they want to do.
Um, as per the guidelines of the American
pediatric association.
And we've talked about it probably 20 or 30
times on the show and I, I don't have anything
new to say about it.
What do you make of the fact that it's so
much lower in many other countries?
I don't make much of it, quite frankly.
Are these countries just negligence?
Can emit uninformed about the benefits?
No, I would not make any assertion about how
informed, you know, I don't live in other
countries, so I wouldn't be able to tell you
their level of informed or uninformed
and the, uh, AP no longer recommended the
procedure.
So why would you continue doing it?
Sorry, the AEP,
the AAP,
AAP.
Oh, uh, feel free to send me whatever report
you're referring to and I'll take a look at
it.
Okay.
All right.
Thanks very much.